hmm now by the way these are what my
pages look like for these answers not
because I was expecting you to make two
right answers like this my answers
always include more answers than you
actually need it tends to include all
possible answers right but there are
lots of answers for these questions so
if you ever got to these bits and I felt
like either is a time constraint or
people looked at these questions in our
like I don't know what to do okay um
theory there are many answers right so
let's let's start with section C no one
else is on there yet so I'm going to
wait until until it loads up that's okay
that's okay your computer hbu up and
that kind of thing getting there Steve
where's yours up to sous-vide okay well
in that case while we're waiting I'll
just open this up and we'll just do it
the old-fashioned way because you know
interactive whiteboards and touch
screens and while I kind of think of
really old fashioned spec okay sure you
should we give this yet I'll start off
by reading the question give you a bit
of context because been a while so let's
remember the entertainment industry is
often at the forefront of technology
developments which is unsurprising since
it has access to massive funds running
into the tens of millions of dollars for
individual productions such as video
games and movies okay so by the way can
you see now I wonder if you remember
when I gave you the prologue to this
exam right and I said look here's sort
of what your section C or research is
going to be about this is what will
guide your research I hope you can see
the connection it was all about okay
look movies video games all these kinds
of entertainment focus things they drive
a lot of Technology it's quite amazing
how much they do anyway that's gone
these huge quantities of money enable
the industry to develop the best tools
and also to devote massive numbers of
artists and engineers to using those
tools to create immersive experiences
whether it's in a movie theater or the
lounge room okay first question says for
a party
demonstrate ways in which the
entertainment industry relies heavily
upon advanced communications and
database systems to generate revenue
that's just money profits okay right
let's just try and break apart the
question a little bit first demonstrate
mmm now I know that's not a very
frequently used HSE keyword but you know
this is an open test so you might have
even have did anyone bring you in a list
of HSE key words and their definitions
aha that woke a so anyway you're not
going to get another African test but
you really got to know them what does
them astray mean does anyone know now
morning demonstrate demonstrate like
what would be the difference between
demonstrate ways that the entertainment
industry does is versus say outline if I
said outline ways what would that mean
what's the difference between outlines
and demonstrates hmm okay maybe I should
pose this question to if I asked you to
outline ways to cook an egg outline ways
to cook it in okay what might you
respond to me what why you say okay I
might take up first you might you might
want to boil it okay so you would
describe this that's where you put the
water on and then you get egg and so on
okay or am I take you could purchase and
so on it's all right now if I said
demonstrate demonstrate ways to cook an
egg okay what's the difference that's
the difference the digitech outline and
demonstrate or even describe and
Democrat is that I'm going to show it to
you by example I'm not just going to say
look you can do this or you could do
that I'm actually gonna get neg out and
do it right so when it says demonstrate
ways that the entertainment industry
relies heavily upon these systems right
you've got to show those ways by
examples you've got to give examples
that's why this is in the research
chicken okay so because there are two
kinds of systems that I'm after
communications and database systems
let's break it up in that work
communications systems will do that
first and then we want to databases okay
right now I think most people were
better at this part then the second part
the databases bit but it was still a bit
of shambles okay by the way where we are
two people are here yet yeah we've got
people okay so i i'm looking at i'm not
going to draw it because it's i will be
messaged you guys to do a better job but
let's try this okay so first way TV
everyone mentioned TV so that's good but
what's the actual communications
technology that they're relying on you
guys know a lot about communication
systems they had this great what kind of
communication systems is is TV what
direction is it going is it is it a
two-way communication TV TV it's not
right it just goes from the network to
the viewers so it's a simpler set now
you didn't have to say simplex but they
said kinds of things which is it ready
sir um these are the kinds of things I
should demonstrate that you know what
kind of communication system is so for
instance this is the way that I'll take
I'm TV and also radio right these
networks they broadcast simplex signals
now think remember the question says how
do they generate revenue how they rely
on these sisters to generate revenue
okay well TV and radio what I do they
don't just broadcast shows they
broadcast along with the shows and in
between shows advertisements thank you
and that's how they get money right so
they broadcast simplex signals right
that combined content and embedded
advertising now embedded advertising
that's not a special phrase it's just
that the advertising is embedded within
the content so if you want to watch the
content you sort of get forced to watch
the advertising unless you're very
vigilant and turn it off when the ads
come on occasion like I am in principle
opposed to ads right now that was me
saying that was me outlining it okay
they broadcasting rules that have
content and they have advertising how am
I going to demonstrate that what
concrete example is could I give of TV
networks at dinner there's no watch TV
and the other names thank you okay seven
nine and ten
no well ABC not reassessment okay um
what about radio networks wonderful i
wanted a fair mix for this is 25 okay
look those are actual examples let's
show by example that's the difference in
demonstrate at outline okay let's move
on to another on so oh that's
interesting ok so number one I said TV
radio and I said that's that's kind of a
free-to-air right now then that's not
the only kind of TV there is right what
other kinds of TV on it page a bit cable
right so they generate revenue in
different ways okay so cable and
satellite TV here's my second point ok
so number one free to FTA yeah that'll
work free TV ok next one cable or
satellite TV now it's important that you
say cable or satellite because cable
satellite are different communication
system are you following me yeah this is
make sense just free to air it's not
just a touch of stuff it's not about the
freeness eva is over the air it's it's
transmitted by you know you've got a TV
aerial on top of your TV right so it's
freely available whereas came on
satellite I'm not freely available right
because you actually need technology to
access it if you're going to get cable
TV what do you need 22 things now like a
satellite TV don't think you got to have
this huge dish on top of your roof I
don't know if you've my father-in-law is
enormous digital it looks kind of silly
actually but you need that piece of
technology communication assistance
access it your cable TV you're going to
need a set-top box right like Fox still
IQ or something like that and then
you're obviously going to need the cable
connection that goes underneath the
ground ok or along the telegraph poles
usually under the ground and not every
place has that ok so there's the actual
communication system we're relying on
what a semi Devils our arrangement we've
already mentioned Fox liq you can pick
out any kind of cable TV subscription
service like your blog all that kind of
thing they're demonstrated by example
okay okay so Kate will satellite pay-tv
in other words right what's another
example okay the internet ever
I was like the internet but no one gave
me specific or very few people gave you
a specific example so let me give you
one okay who uses the internet to
generator you will say people like
record labels or film studios they're
going to sell digital content directly
to consumers right and the great thing
about that is that you get rid of the
middleman the retail middleman people
like sanity or hmb right who take their
cut inevitably you get your cut taken
out somewhere else like say Apple for
itunes that kind of thing right they'll
take a thirty percent coverage is quite
high but through the internet you can
sell digital content directly to
consumers so that's how they're
generating revenue and they're relying
on this communication system sometimes
you see how I'm going through the
communications this is one by one and
I'm giving you examples to pick out a
couple water brothers I don't know my
gosh disney pixar whoever okay they're
all selling through the internet okay
what else I what other kinds of systems
are we missing here this kind of
internet we could generalize that to a
wireless internet more specifically you
can say things like say mobile coverage
right that enables the sale of
entertainment content and related apps
all these mobile devices now that's a
whole other revenue stream on time right
so I've got 3d TV pay-tv sort of
grounded internet and then you've got
cellular data okay that's a whole new
communication system that the media
industry is relying on does that make
sense yeah it's a new system and they
rely on it in a different kind of way
okay so there's this for right i think i
was looking for two or three I'd also my
go on I've got tons more sorry let's
okay we've got it someone else want to
put down mobile internet or cellular
data okay here's another one because the
internet it actually spawns a whole
bunch of different ways of getting money
ok so here was an obvious one which I
was surprised no one picked up on I
don't think maybe one person online
crowdfunding crowdfunding what does
crowdfunding me
crowd funding yeah yeah yeah it's a
sponsorship system right so instead of
you know I've already got my big product
and it's already i'm a huge company i
won hundreds of millions of dollars
right and i can create all my content
and then sell to whoever i like a
distributor right crowd funding is like
I'm a little guy I don't have all that
capital already so i'm going to say hey
guys do you like this idea what do you
think of this idea what do you think of
a Veronica Mars movie right which I
don't know if anyone's actually looked
up for anything Mars was a very troubled
TV series but it got funding on
kickstarter Kickstarter I hope you've
heard of Kickstarter before so online
crowdfunding platforms crowdfunding is a
single word by the way such as
Kickstarter and there's that there's my
specific example says they demonstrate
right there connect creators to support
of communities right and a facilitator
revenue transfer it's quite direct in
that way right again Kickstarter takes
their cut but still so to sponsor your
program and the important thing is it
creates it creates a connection between
the content creators and the communities
that directly want to support them ok ok
one more under internet anyway um gamers
gamers that's a massive party
entertainment industry right so for
example things like multiplayer games
how do they work how do they work what
what systems are they relying on more
specifically than the internet what
could we say I then no gamers in the
room 9 so I said yeah yeah that's ok so
I've got a good service online blizzard
for instance my run all these massive
servers for their world of warcraft
stuff back to pack of thing so you've
got simulation type online games like
World of Warcraft or like Call of Duty
or whatever you play ok but those are
the only kinds of games online right
what kinds of games people play online
come on you're on facebook and you get
invite for farmville or candy crush to
thank you ok all these kinds of games
now again they're relying on
communication systems right does this
make sense they're using cloud or local
based communication system
two league players together and then you
know how do they have they actually
generate the money number one in-game
purchases number two which tends to be
for those social games like farmville
make i think is a free right or actually
just to buy the game call of duty it's
not cheap right so they're they're
earning revenue that way and then
supporting it with this communication
system right because imagine if there
was no internet who would buy call of
duty a few people right the limited
scope of people who actually just want
to play the single player game and just
place your campaign I'm interested in
story but the vast majority of players
are in it because there's a
communication system underneath it that
lets people play together that's why
it's such a vibrant community ok so a
call of duty halo whatever kinds of
examples you want to pick out you have
to give some specifically ok good so all
of these come under communication
systems right let's move on to databases